Speaker 1: We start today with stunning
hypocrisy. Republican Congressman James Comer
was asked by CNN's Jake TAPPER. Okay. You're
investigating or you want to investigate Joe
Biden's handling of classified documents. After 15
or 20 documents were found in Biden's possession,
which his lawyers immediately contacted the
National Archives and turned over. Fine. You
want to investigate that, But then you must also
want to investigate Donald Trump, right? I mean,
Trump had at least hundreds of documents and
Trump deliberately took them. And Trump used
lawyers to try to avoid giving them back rather
than immediately turning them over. Clearly,
if you're investigating Biden, you must also
want to investigate Trump and James Colmer
can't explain why he's investigating Joe Biden
and not Donald Trump. This is brazen hypocrisy.
Obvious partizanship a humiliating double
standard, but. It's Republican politics in 2023,
and it has been for a while. Let's take a look.
And Jake TAPPER visibly exasperated because what
James Colmer is saying makes no sense whatsoever.
Speaker 2: Let's go there because you're talking
about the Trump documents. Former President
Trump is under an investigation for his own
classified documents. There are about 20 in the
case of Biden and Trump, there are about there
are more than 300 classified documents. Mar a
Lago, a big difference here just on the facts.
Trump did not fully comply with the subpoena.
His lawyers falsely told investigators that they
turned everything in. True. Take a listen to what
you told CNN about the situation last November.
Speaker 1: This gets good.
Speaker 3: I don't know much about
that. That's not something that we've requested
information just to see what was going on, because
I don't know what documents were at Mar a Lago.
Speaker 1: So, by the way, Mar a Lago. Listen,
we went to Mar a Lago and there were no documents,
right? Well, because that's not the place.
Speaker 3: It's something we're just
waiting to see what comes out in that.
Speaker 4: But is it fair to say that
investigation will be a priority?
Speaker 3: That will not be a.
Speaker 2: So what do you say to
viewers who don't understand why President Biden's
documents seem like a big priority for you? Yeah,
but President Trump, who took hundreds more
documents, did not comply with the subpoena,
did not reach out to the National Archives
or the Justice Department to say, hey,
we found these documents. It's not a priority.
Do you only care about classified documents being
mishandled when Democrats do the mishandling?
Speaker 1: Yes, that's absolutely right. Right,
Jake, I'm a partizan hack.
Speaker 3:
Absolutely not. But we still don't know what type
of documents President Trump had. That's one of
the questions we've asked National Archives. Just
because Joe Biden's lawyer said they turned over
five documents doesn't mean they just turned over
five documents. They could have turned over 500
documents. I'm sorry, but I don't have a lot of
confidence in President Biden's personal lawyers.
At the end of the day, the National Archives
implied to us at former Chairman Maloney's
request and told us that the National Archives
was working with the Trump administration during
the transition. That's the last communication we
had with whether or not the archives had worked.
Speaker 1: If you are confused and you're
wondering where is the answer about why we
care more about the Biden thing than the
Trump thing with the documents. If you're
searching in this clip for that answer,
it's not there. That's why you're confused.
Speaker 3: Trump on removal of all the documents
from the White House. Yeah, we don't know
exactly what Trump has versus what Biden has.
Speaker 1: And part of the reason they don't know
if is they've said the Trump aspect of this just
isn't a priority. They're not trying to find out.
Speaker 3: End of the day, my biggest concern is
that the classified documents, to be honest with
you, my concern is how there's such a discrepancy
in how former President Trump was treated by
raising our logo, by getting the security cameras,
by taking pictures of documents on the wall.
Speaker 1: This is a circle I hope that many of
you recognize. This is completely circular. He
says, listen, I don't care so much about the
difference in the documents. I care about the
difference in how they were treated. But
of course, to understand the difference
in how they've been treated so far, you have to
understand the difference between the documents.
You have to understand the difference. We did the
number of documents. You have to understand that,
Trump said. Take these documents to my house.
Whereas with Joe Biden, everything we know is that
we're talking about somewhere between one and two
dozen documents that Joe Biden didn't say, keep
these put these in a box and put them next to my
Corvette. This clearly was an oversight which was
immediately turned over to the National Archives.
If you don't understand that, then you wouldn't
understand the difference in the treatment.
But that's exactly what James Colmer wants.
Speaker 3: Going through Melania's closet.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Okay. So that's a complete
inability or unwillingness to explain what the
difference is. And James Colmer doesn't have
any answers because the answer is actually the
simplest one. He's a Partizan hack and he only
cares about the Biden documents because Biden's
a Democrat and Colmer is a Republican. Now,
Jake TAPPER tried again on this and said, okay,
why are you asking for the visitor logs for the
Biden White House, for Joe Biden, rather, but not
for Mar-A-Lago or Mar a Lago, as Colmer said. And
it's the answer. Well, just whatever the opposite
is of a light bulb going off. That's what it is.
Speaker 2: I get that. But there's a big
difference in how President Biden and his team.
Speaker 1: Sorry, this is the wrong clip. Okay.
Here. Nope, that's okay. I don't have the clip.
All right. Well, that's too bad. That went.
That went bad. Anyway, I don't know where the
clip went and I apologize that the clip has
disappeared. The question from TAPPER was,
why are you asking for the visitor logs for Biden
and not from Mar a Lago? And James Colmer said,
well, we're in the middle of a Biden family
influence peddling investigation, which is,
of course, an investigation that we knew they
would do, but is a complete distraction from
actual things taking place in the real world.
So even Republicans aren't able to explain why
the Biden documents are a big deal, but the Trump
documents are not. We are left to speculate. My
speculation takes me to well, it's because Trump's
a Republican and these hacks are also Republicans.